[Musique]
cool merci beaucoup
alors une petite phrase pour commencer
prononcé par shimon perez
il ya quelques temps le monde a changé
un nouveau monde est apparu mais
l'ancien tarder à disparaître
l'ancien a du mal à partir
le nouveau a du mal à éclore
effectivement je pense qu'on est dans
cette période un petit peu charnière que
l'on vit que l'on ressent ce que je vous
propose dans un premier temps c'est
partager avec vous le regard d'une jeune
femme de 30 ans une jeune française avec
tous les biais que ça comporte une
entrepreneure avec tout ce que ça
implique qu'ils aient pas plus
intelligente que plein d'autres experts
aux cheveux blancs mais qui a minima
s'intéressent à ce sujet ait envie
d'avoir de l'impact quand on prend du
recul sur la période sur l'époque sur le
monde qui est le nôtre
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire on peut dire
qu'il est traversé par des ruptures qui
sont profondes
la première façon de qualifier ces
transformations ça serait la
postmodernité un monde post moderne la
post modernité ça a été théorisée
initialement par lio tard
qui dit finalement où vivait une
histoire dirigé par le progrès ça
c'était l'époque moderne mais que ses
potes cette époque moderne et plus le
progrès a changé ensuite vous avez
maffesoli qui a traduit sa dont les
institutions qui sont les nôtres
en dix ans ce qui se passe à l'heure
actuelle sont des institutions issues de
l'époque moderne reposant sur le
triptyque la raison l'individualité et
le progrès qui sont à la ramasse d'une
société civile d'un monde d'une planète
qui est passé dans la post modernité et
que ce tiraillement que l'on vit basse
et c'est le le lit ça fait le livre la
crise de sens que l'on ressent la post
modernité à moi j'la traduirait manière
vachement différentes
je parlerai d'un alignement des planètes
je pense que ce qu'on vit à l'heure
actuelle c'est une remise en cause
extrêmement profond de tous les grands
modèles économiques et financiers
sociétaux et environnementaux
un septième continent de plastique qui
flottent dans le pacifique idéologique
politique avec la faillite des
institutions politiques en france au
niveau de l'onu un peu partout il ya
comme un alignement de ces planètes là
qu'ils ont été des planètes fondatrice
de nos sociétés modernes et qui vont
devoir être réinventée dans les années à
venir
les mecs vous arrivez sur une planète où
tous les grands modèles qui ont
structuré nos cadres de pensée nos
sociétés jusqu'à présent vont devoir
être réinventer complètement vous allez
devoir créer votre héritage et ça c'est
quelque chose dont on a conscience alors
qu'on formalise avec plumes ont plus ou
moins d'aisance et dont on a conscience
aux quatre coins du globe derrière la
conscience de ce sujet et à la
responsabilité parce qu'on peut se dire
effectivement il ya un truc qui est en
train de se passer
il ya un défi gigantesque de refonte et
de réinvention
mais il m'appartient à moi entre autres
avec les autres de proposer des choses
et puis derrière la responsabilité ya la
chance pour avoir de l'impact de pouvoir
faire bouger les lignes
à ce moment particulier de l'histoire de
l'humanité ceci pour la post modernité
qu'est qu'une façon de voir le monde qui
vous entoure
il ya une autre façon de voir le monde
qui nous entoure une traduction un peu
de la postmodernité dans l'économie
c'est le post matérialisme le post
matérialisme ça a été développé par une
gueule art repris plus récemment par
daniel cohen dans un livre au titre
extraordinaire mambo le monde est clos
et le désir infini
qu'est ce qui dit il explique un truc
très simple
la révolution numérique est une
révolution industrielle pour laquelle
les auteurs et les chercheurs se casse
la figure pour savoir c'est la troisième
ou la quatrième peu importe c'est une
révolution industrielle
elle a une caractéristique majeure c'est
une révolution industrielle
sans croissance les chiffres en
attestent
et une enquête a été réalisée par the
guardian ya quelques mois sur les sept
économies occidentales et les
vingtenaires c'est à dire les digital
natives les bébés de cette révolution
industrielle qu'elle arrivait
numérique et qui montre qu'aujourd'hui
c'est vingtenaires vivent en dessous du
niveau national de leur pays respectif
aux etats unis ces trente dernières
années le pouvoir d'achat n'a pas
augmenté pour 90 % de la population
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'on est en train d'assister à un
changement de paradigme absolument
gigantesque jusqu'à présent l'idée de
progrès dont on parle en post modernité
ça se traduisait de la manière suivante
y aura pas de problème
demain ça sera mieux qu'hier toujours et
le ça sera mieux qu'hier le progrès se
traduisait par de la croissance
c'était ça le paradis messi a plus de
croissance dans les sociétés qui sont
les nôtres qui sont postmoderne
par quoi on va remplacer la croissance
demain ça sera pas mieux qu'hier ça sera
résolument super différents il
n'appartient qu'à nous de décider ce
qu'on met à la place de la croissance
vous n'avez certains qui prédisent ce
que c'est presque un travail de devant
la créativité et l'innovation
d'autres qui parlent du bien-être
d'autres encore des connaissances la
fameuse économie de la connaissance
toujours est il qu'à côté de la
postmodernité ya le post matérialisme
qu'il faut bien avoir en tête
il ya une autre rupture que l'on vit à
l'heure actuelle qui qualifie le monde
qui est le nôtre c'est la rupture
temporel le monde n'ait jamais n'a
jamais été aussi rapides qu'aujourd'hui
quand vous interrogez des chefs
d'entreprise en france et à l'étranger
sur ce qui les interpellent ce qu'il est
fou droits sur ce qu'ils observent au
quotidien ghz
l'accélération du temps la formidable
accélération du temps effectivement
quand on descend un peu dans les
chiffres c'était look en accélération
démographique ya dix mille ans on était
10 millions dans 20 ans sera 10
milliards accélération sociologique le
rythme des générations la génération des
baby boomers et 25 ans la génération y
la mienne c'est 15 ans la génération z 4
à moins de 10 ans ça veut dire qu'on
n'arrive plus à figer une culture
commune un socle de référentiels de
valeur de réflexes qui vont consolider
une génération tellement ça va beaucoup
plus vite
accélération technologique il a fallu 36
entre l'invention du poste de radio et
sa diffusion à 50 millions d'appareils
il a fallu à 4 ans à internet
accélération business la valeur
boursière de airbnb est supérieure à
celle de hayat plus marriott airbnb sa a
été créée il ya huit ans hayat sa a été
créée il ya 60 ans accélération de la
connaissance tous les deux jours on
produit plus de data de données que
l'humanité en a produit 1 2 million
d'années le temps va de plus en plus
vite
et bientôt on aura plus de temps avec le
transhumanisme pour courir après ce
temps qui va de plus en plus vite
rupture temporal mais également rupture
spatial il en train de se passer un truc
dont on prend probablement pas la mesure
c'est l'avènement de ce qu'on pourrait
appeler le glocal le glocal c'est une
génération mondialisé qui agit au niveau
local des individus qui sont glauco il
pense ce mondial ils agissent locales et
pour ma grand mère c'est inconcevable
elle ne peut pas apprendre appréhender
la planète terre dans sa globalité
elle comprend pas ce que ça veut dire
elle n'a jamais voyagé pour ma mère
c'est très compliqué à comprendre qu'on
se sentent davantage touchée par une
catastrophe humanitaire ou écologiques à
des milliers de kilomètres que par le
destin politique de son pays
et pourtant c'est la réalité des
générations d'aujourd'hui et celle de
demain qui pensent mondiale agissent
localement
et puis une dernière rupture alors
celle-ci dont on parle énormément
rupture anthropologique avec cette
fameuse révolution numérique qui est
selon michel serres la troisième
révolution anthropologique majeur de
l'histoire de l'humanité
après l'écriture et l'imprimerie dans la
mesure où elle bouleverse un certain
nombre de codes et dans la mesure
surtout elle façonne un nouvel individu
un homo sapiens sapiens qui a la
capacité d'augmenter son propre corps
cas surtout un super pouvoir dans ses
mains le pouvoir d'impacter le monde qui
est le sien des individus glauco dans un
monde où toutes les planètes se sont
alignés pour dire attention
objectif réinvention c'est la façon dont
moi j'appréhende le monde qui est le
nôtre
et pourtant quand on regarde les mots
vous avez la post modernité
vous avez la révolution vous avez la
disruption vous avez la transformation
tous ces mots là ce sont des mots qui
sont hyper stressant hyper angoissant
on peut dire c'est super cool en fait
c'est une chance de pouvoir impacté mon
univers la réalité c'est quand même que
la plupart des gens sont hyper qui est
hyper angoissé de ce qui est en train de
se passer
tous ces mots là qu'est ce qu'on fait on
tente de les apaiser
ces mots m ax en y apposant des mots et
maux ts qui sont des espèces demorand
par des mots bouclier pour réduire une
réalité pour s'en protéger ces mots
remparts qu'est ce que c'est c'est
d'abord le mot crise elle s'assit
partout la crise c'est la merde c'est la
crise la main en main très bien une
crise ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'on est dans un système qui est
défaillant mais que du coup si on remet
des trucs dans l'ordre ça va bien
refonctionner demain dire qu'on est en
crise et une bonne façon de ne pas
regarder la réalité en face
on n'est pas en crise on est en train de
changer d'air on est en train de changer
de société
on est à la croisée des chemins pour les
choix qu'on va faire demain on a le
pouvoir de changer d'humanité ça c'est
pas une crise on s'appelle une mutation
sociétale global
il ya un autre mot qui est très
révélateur un mot bouclier un mort en
par ces mots précarité c'est la
traduction un peu cette histoire de
crise dans le monde du travail
on est des génération précaire bout
c'est horrible il est trop méchant du
travail
mais la précarité est-ce qu'on peut pas
l'avoir d'une autre manière en disant
que se moquer devenu péjoratif c'est pas
le bon parce qu'ils étaient trop connoté
parce que la réalité de demain c'est
qu'on va devoir être agile qu'on va
devoir être flexible on va devoir
réinventer ses compétences en permanence
on va devoir être entre
preneur de sa vie voire ambassadeur de
sa vie et ça c'est une autre façon de
voir le sujet qu'est carrément plus cool
on fait quelque chose de complexe une
force pour demain on se tire pas une
balle dans le pied en se disant ben
voilà génération précaire et jeux sont
faits tant pis pour moi hubert isation
ça aussi c'est un autre moins
intéressant moi mon quotidien c'est
travailler des entreprises et en ce
moment il ya un grand stress c'est le
stress de l'ubs et riza sion mais qu'est
ce que ça veut dire en fait quand on va
un petit peu plus loin ça veut dire quoi
être eu des risées pas ce sont des
grandes entreprises que une histoire qui
ont un capital humain qui ont un capital
immatériel font peur de mourir c'est rue
berri zay ça veut dire j'aime faire
dévorer par les jeunes j'aime faire
dévorer par 2016 gelé disparaître alors
que se fait rue berri 0 réalité ça veut
dire voilà les règles du jeu business
avait vachement changer va falloir être
innovant sortir de sa zone de confort va
falloir se réinventer valeur passer d'un
état stable un état instable va falloir
créer des entreprises qui sont mutante
va falloir remettre le capital humain au
coeur du système pour que les hommes
s'engagent pour qui transforme votre
boîte ça c'est quand même super nouvelle
une fois qu'on se dise ah qu'est ce
qu'on fait une fois qu'on est là et
qu'on voit les gros trous noirs confirme
sa mère de ce qui se passe de l'autre
côté
qu'est ce qu'on fait on fait un truc
très simple je crois c'est en sautant en
parachute
le but c'est pas de créer un pont de
faire une rampe de lancement
non parce qu'en fait on est dans un
changement de société dans un changement
d'air dans un changement le monde va
falloir armées sont parachutés sauter
pour sauter va falloir avoir confiance
confiance en qui en l'avenir
l'avenir c'est qui c'est la jeunesse
confiance en soi et vous pouvez avec
tous les témoignages que vous avez
entendu aujourd'hui avoir sauté puis va
falloir leur voler et pour voler il faut
du vent et je crois que le vont en fait
ce sont les idées
nous y voilà soit le seul moyen de
s'affranchir de ce passé qui vient si
lourd qu'il nous rend inerte de cette
peur qui est paralysante
ce sont les idées il nous faut des idées
pour construire aujourd'hui pour
construire demain
et du coup il nous faut des idées
portées par des hommes et des femmes qui
vont les incarner mais surtout qu'ils
vont en prendre la responsabilité
parce que c'est là le coeur du message
que je voulais faire passer ce soir
c'est que une idée c'est super mais sans
une ou plusieurs personnes derrière qui
ne prend pas la responsabilité cette
idée ça sert à rien et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui dans un contexte où les
enjeux sont politiques au sens noble du
terme
la responsabilité qui incombe aux gens
qui ont des idées
elle est double la première c'est de
partager l'information de communiquer de
donner des grilles de lecture sur ce qui
est en train de se passer
là c'est super cool on est tous ensemble
j'espère que vous êtes content c'est
hyper intéressant mais c'est pas ça la
société la plupart du des gens qui ont
besoin d'avoir ses grilles de lecture
ces éléments de compréhension de ce qui
est en train de se passer de ce qu'ils
ressentent sans pouvoir le formaliser et
donc l'accepter et donc avoir envie
demain ils sont pas dans cette pièce
ils sont devant leur télé à regarder
cyril hanouna et jamais de la vie ils
vont avoir un tête comme ça sur tf1 ou
sur m6 jamais de la vie
du coup la responsabilité numéro un de
ceux qui ont des idées pour aujourd'hui
de ceux qui ont compris ce qui est en
train de se passer c'est de les partager
sinon on va créer des sociétés qui sont
fracturées c'est globalement déjà ce qui
est en train de se passer entre ce
qu'ils vivent qui vibre et ceux qui vont
payer la double peine c'est à dire la
disparition du monde hier et
l'incompréhension du monde de demain
qu'ils ne pourront pas aimer parce qu'il
ne le comprennent pas parce que les
intellectuels et politiques les
entrepreneurs n'auront pas pris le temps
de venir expliquer ce qui est en train
de se passer
la responsabilité d la responsabilité
des idées c'est ça la responsabilité des
idées c'est aussi de proposer on peut
analyser ce qui se passe aujourd'hui il
faut proposer faut proposer pourquoi
d'abord parce qu'on en a ras-le-bol des
diagnostics enfin moi à titre personnel
donc le on est un peu inclusif
je passe ma vie dans des colloques dans
des trucs à écouter des gens hyper
brillant hyper intelligent mais ils
racontent tous la même chose la mini
synthèse que je vous ai fait
en introduction sur ce qui était en
train de se passer on l'entend partout
quand on va voir justement ces cercles
d'initiés
l'heure n'est plus au diagnostic je
pense que globalement on a compris
l'heure est à la proposition la propolis
la proposition je pense que c'est une
responsabilité nationale et globale pour
la simple et bonne raison qu'en fait le
destin il n'est pas écrit
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
on est on est flipper de sauter dans le
dans l'espèce de ravin là parce qu'on se
dit on sait pas s'il ya notre côté mais
si ça se trouve il ya des noms des trucs
horribles ces langues faire pour demain
mais non en fait parce que la bonne
nouvelle c'est que vous allez écrire
de l'autre côté de laval aise au fur et
à mesure que vous allez avancé c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne le destin on
subit pas en choisit on construit donc
la responsabilité quand on a des idées
c'est qu'on propose qui propose qui doit
proposer
y a pas d'homme providentiel ça fait
deux ans que je suis en face de gens qui
me disent on attend quelqu'un pour venir
nous sauver c'est pas du tout une blague
et je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui pensent comme ça on attend un homme
politique génial un captain france
quelqu'un qui va venir et qui va dire
t'inquiète pas cocotte c'est bon je vais
tout régler j'ai tout compris j'assure
un max
repose toi mais non mais ça ça n'existe
pas en fait je pense que ça n'existe pas
que ça n'a jamais existé mais que dans
le momentum que l'on vit à l'heure
actuelle c'est encore moins possible et
qu'on n'a pas le droit d'attendre un
captain france parce qu'en réalité celui
qui en capacité de proposer des idées
pas c'est vous c'est vous dans cette
salle c'est vous qui avez le pouvoir et
je crois que justement l'idée de ce tête
de tous ces têtes qui se succéder
c'était de vous montrer que cette
responsabilité c'est la vôtre
donc le qui c'est vous c'est nous c'est
tout le monde est en fait c'est
vachement dur de se dire ça c'était
tellement plus facile d'attendre un
homme providentiel en vrai c'est
tellement plus lourd à porter dû se dire
qu'effectivement dans le monde qui est
le nôtre le pouvoir
est entre nos mains au niveau individuel
et collectif équipe si on prend pas la
mesure de sa c'est pas nous qui nous en
mordront les doigts sont les générations
à venir
ce que mon dernier point c'est celui ci
proposer des idées pour qui est bien
pour nous pour vos enfants pour mes
enfants
il ya une notion qui est
extraordinairement absente des débats
actuels c'est la notion d'héritage
est-ce qu'on va être collectivement fier
de ce qu'on est en train de faire nous
populations charnière est-ce qu'on a
seulement en tête que les choix
d'aujourd'hui sont des choix qui vont
être déterminants pour les 50 et 100
prochaines années
est ce qu'on va pouvoir se regarder dans
une glace
tout là-haut je n'en sais rien
une phrase qui m'a beaucoup inspiré jean
guéhenno qui dit la vraie trahison c'est
de suivre le monde comme il va et
d'employer son esprit à le justifier
soyez libres soyez rebelles merci
[Applaudissements]